اعلن البنتاجون ان الولايات المتحده نفذت
غارات على منشات تابعه لكتائب حزب الله
العراقيه ومجموعات اخرى تابعه لها ووصف
البنتاجون الضربات الجويه بانها ضروريه
وجاءت ردا على هجوم في وقت سابق للاثنين
استهدف قاعده اربيل الامريكيه وقواعد اخرى
في كل من العراق وسوريا واوضح البنتاجون
ان الهجوم الذي استهدف قاعده امريكيه في
اربيل خلف ثلاثه اصابات او ثلاث اصابات
احداها خطيره وقال وزير الدفاع لويد اوستن
في البيان المكتوب ان واشنطن لن تتوانى في
الدفاع عن المصالح الامريكيه وهي مستعده
لاتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه لحمايه مصالحها من
جهته اعلن متحدث باسم البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس جو بايدن هو من امر بالهجمات
الامريكيه ضد كتائب حزب الله
العراقيه